to put the thirst traps away at what age
um well okay I feel like it's okay to
thirst crap in order to get a man and as
soon as you meet him and you're like
this is my relationship you take all the
thirst traps down I think that's okay
but in general I feel like 30 it's got
to be a wrap just for your own dignity
it would be nice if they stop sooner but
most women probably won't but I think 30
is when you probably just should we'll
give them 32. let's give them 32. let's
give an extra two years I just like
Diane why don't you put the phone down
I mean it's worse than that because the
thing is is that the older the older
that harlots get you know they'll be
with their family on social media and
they'll still be posting thirst traps
and you'll just be sitting there as like
you know the niece or the daughter
you're like why and why like please stop
this makes me uncomfortable I don't want
your coochie on my screen oh my God and
then when you unfollow them they're like
why do I follow
my
phone
because it's weird to see like family in
a provocative pose yeah that's
uncomfortable you know the funny thing
is too is the moms that are in denial of
their daughters being that way they're
in denial of their daughters there's
trapping they're like oh she's just a
beautiful young woman I'm like that's it
I'm like I just don't know I just saw
her ass I've been looking at
oh um also also
that's what I should say
all the people that are coming at me
right now all the people that are coming
at me right now and they're saying that
you know I was just given this right how
stressed out am I 24 7. oh yeah well
this one's fun and because now I get to
talk about her friendship because I
don't I don't talk about it like without
you because that's weird but um no like
Pearl doesn't work I tell this story we
went to her dad's mcmansion and the
beach was within walking distance and me
I'm like cool I'm gonna go to the beach
it's right there in the backyard this
woman was working the whole time and I
was like hey you know like don't you
think you should go to the beach like
isn't this what your dad worked for this
woman like looked at me in my face and
was like well this is this is the norm
to me yeah yeah and that's the thing
like a lot of people they want to be
where I'm at but they don't want to do
the [ __ ] that I've done and I sort of
got the last couple years I have not had
a life I will soon I'm gonna get two
million and then she's lying no I'm
gonna relax in a million I'm gonna relax
okay okay but it's like it's like then
people be like oh how did we let her get
here look what do you mean let me get
there I got here like I myself you just
don't sleep but you like working as much
as you complain about it sometimes I'm
like you'll never quit no I'm gonna I
swear to God I'm gonna give it a million
I'm gonna relax I mean I'm still gonna
work but I'm gonna work last 7 million
million that's when I want to relax I
think you'll be an efficient mom because
you'll find some way to make a program
out of it I'm pretty sure
how can I level up my child well my
children will be entrepreneurs oh okay
just like my parents like I just feel
like it was a good way to grow up like
and my parents were they were just very
business savvy and they just always
encourage us to be entrepreneurs and
follow what we like I'm gonna look at
the chat there could be some good
questions here um
but yeah you know um to me what I think
is weird and kind of feminine is the men
that hate on you for being successful oh
yeah because it's like how you want in a
a Midwest white girl show you uh that's
what obsidian said it is true like how
this how this little bright happy joyful
25 year old outworking these grown men
sad sad
no I don't knock anyone that doesn't
want to do what I do
it's a lot of work and it's really
tiring but it's like
how are you gonna hate on me when you
didn't do what I did how many of you
posted 20 times in one day I have I have
I'm not above it the comment section
will be like stop it we don't want that
much posting and I'm like I don't care
they're like modern women they don't
know what they want but that's true your
audience doesn't know they don't know
what they like until you show it to them
you know what I mean and so it's like I
would I would subscribe and hit the
notification Bell just like see what
gets thrown my way you know just see
um okay
tales of the whales that's good Perla
sodium tall that she sits the same
height as Ally sitting down yeah you
know if I kind of like walking around
with pearl I feel like I got a little
bodyguard
okay yo but I think you wouldn't have to
physically hurt anyone and Northern do I
think you would but I think you're so
good at talking that you can probably
talk your way out of any situation yeah
I feel like if somebody robbed me like I
could just be like why do you do that oh
okay like come on my podcast don't rob
me again
I'm gonna try to talk about I'm like why
are you doing this look you have to have
some other skills like let's let's talk
about
somebody somebody's asking tell me when
you're ready all right okay somebody's
asking if I have any kids I have one but
it's really little that I'm still
growing I'm growing a baby it's on the
way give me give me some time it's not
good enough you're not travel with no I
got 11 tattoos I'm never gonna be
traveling like what do you want me to do
I don't even have a father really
talking about oh she's not Trad of
course not
okay oh actually someone messaged me
about making a dating app the other day
I was I was listening but I was like
what would be different about this
dating app I feel like the same thing
would happen well you'd have to make a
staff that would screen people like I
feel like maybe if it's a dating app
that you have to be invited to but
eventually you just get too big to
manage maybe it could be like where the
women actually get their looks matches
yeah I feel like that doesn't make sense
we're like
yeah we do you get like a rating one to
ten from someone but then the problem
isn't they just edit it they'll cheat
they'll find a way to cheat
are you open to questions yeah you guys
can ask questions you guys can ask
questions we're just waiting to leave
if you would have told me a year or two
ago that would be a live streamer I'd be
like what but now it's just fun like I
just did a live stream on Instagram and
I was doing my makeup and I was talking
about uh politics in the past two years
and government uh legislation so I feel
it's a fun gig and uh I don't think I
don't think we try to gatekeep you but I
understand that people are trying to
gatekeep YouTube they're not even making
42 000 a year off it
well I'm like look at I have one-on-one
sessions that you can buy so if you guys
are interested you know go ahead
you know what's crazy YouTube is the
only workplace where people making less
than 42 000 a year try to blend me owe
you like how do you how do you blackmail
me and be broke at the same time I don't
understand but I think we know what
other content creators make because we
do it oh yeah yeah it's like a lot of
the ones that I see that'll have like
I'm not gonna name names I'm not gonna
name names but I'll see like nice car
nice chains whatever it is please yeah
and I'm just like I know what you make
and I I'm if you're making money it's
not from YouTube so
um
but if you guys want to know how to
um shut up you're making more than 42k
but this is okay this is what kind of
sort of no but this is what people don't
understand it's like they just look at
what you made but you have to subtract
it minus expenses so you might make a
lot of money but if you pay a like if
you're paying 30 people 2 000 a month
that's that's you don't take home as
much as people think
um
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
I think people that don't make large
sums of money and I'm not trying to be
rude I don't think they understand how
money works because I I remembered that
um but I knew that so this is not a
bragging moment it's just an example
moment
um I know the cost of my wedding ring
and sometime I ask somebody how much
they thought it cost and they told me a
hundred thousand and I was like no like
this is like wait wait wait
significantly less than that um but yeah
you'll you'll find if you end up with a
really big YouTube platform that you're
going to be if you care about quality
yeah you'll spend like thousands and the
same people you know it's crazy I'm not
gonna name names I'm not gonna name
names but there's certain channels that
call me grifters and I don't sell
anything
I saw nothing I'm like the same channels
they'll have
courses that cost thousands of dollars
I don't sell that and they'll have the
audacity to call me a grifter it's like
I don't know I don't even sell anything
now the only thing I sell is an
entertaining show yeah
and that's a viewership that's not
making me they're like you took all
their money and I'm like
no no they're watching they want to make
men to be victims and but then they'll
complain about feminists making women
victims and it's like people just pay
for what they think is valuable and
honestly I think you know the way that
the world is and the leader the leader
of red pill Andrew Tate would agree with
this Andrew Tate ran only fans thing
right you don't feel that like guys if
people want to pay for something
it's not a it's not and I'm not the same
as an of model do not no but I don't
even know why they say that I know but
it's like it's like why are they trying
to make guys out to be
they're just like helpless just working
over money I mean look Simpson exists
but you can't stop Sims from simping
yeah like I don't know they've been
doing it since the dawn of time it's not
gonna and honestly I really don't get
that many like simply comments like most
of the stuff that people have really
super chatted have been like
I'm like one I I don't know how these
other YouTubers they bring in a lot more
Super Chat money than me super chats is
not the main source of like revenue for
my business but oh no it's like not even
close like I would guess like 10 20 but
um
the biggest super techs have always been
to Rose girls yeah it's really it's
really the opposite of simping it's like
yeah it's like to say that like it's to
like it's honestly just to roast yeah
a rose chat instead of a Super Chat how
tall are you Pro my wife is six three do
you feel like it affects your dating
like negatively yes yes I do I I
actually think that like if you're a
five five girl you can date five five
and up yeah where if you're six foot
girl it's six foot it's a smaller
percentage my husband is five eight
there was a conspiracy on my channel for
a time that I didn't like short guys and
not that I think that my husband is
short but I was like that's really funny
because I I guess I married one by
hypergamous standards a married one so
it's like actually my now that I'm
thinking about it I'm like my channel is
like an anti-sympic like they do the
opposite they roast women yeah
yeah which have five dollar Super Chat
that says people who don't have a
business will never understand Record
Law stated grifter for receipts of super
chats it's a good thing well here's my
thing about rifting conversation I okay
I think everything is a girl furlough
says this that everything's a group but
it's about how much you give back I
think that's true but people acting like
they're not getting drifted on at
Walmart at Taco Bell on Amazon people
getting gifted leftovers like you choose
what you spend your money on I'm sorry
also then there's people messaging me
being like you're not with your export
oh you're not with your boyfriend
anymore you're not married and I'm like
where's this rumor going around let's
say and I'm married I started out
there's been three students like she's
married and she lives at her parents
house I live in London people aren't as
bad at facts I've heard wild stories
about me too like one time there's a
like for some reason people think I was
in a domestic violence relationship for
10 10 years and like that
it's like never happened in my life but
I think the internet just does what it
does oh how do you start trusting others
to get the job done okay no no actually
this is a conversation that I do want to
talk about a lot of content creators are
afraid to Outsource things and I am a
big fan of Outsourcing because and the
biggest thing from other content
creators is they always say like I don't
trust someone with my edits I don't
trust someone with my titles thumbnails
whatever if they suck you fire them and
get another one and eventually you're
gonna get a good one but it's like that
that control it I just think long term
it's better to hire someone
did you say you're ready blessing yeah
okay okay bye guys um Pearl they call
you I'm gonna read this they call you
grifter because you're white in a black
space it's like vanilla ice your height
doesn't affect you in dating you
wouldn't date a shorter dot guy woman
control their prosperity that's true
that's true I'm gonna give you that
sorry
um I will date a slightly shorter guy
I'd like to say I don't think you meant
to be in a blog space I think people
just assume that you're oh my God and
percentage-wise they assume that that is
also your audience but there's a big
difference between guests and audience
but for some reason people keep
confusing the two I don't know yeah and
I don't know I'm a big fan of I was
trying I've been trying to get Rolo on
the stream for like ever
it doesn't look extendable anyways
um I have to go guys we're gonna go do a
video but
um we'll talk to you later bye